[Applause]
[Music]
next time you go for a jog and stream
music off of spotify or apple music it's
increasingly likely a wall street
private equity firm will be collecting
some money
music is one of the hottest new asset
classes drawing interest from pe giants
like blackstone apollo and kkr who
poured more than 3 billion into buying
song catalogs recently
kkr is particularly active purchasing
catalogs like songwriter ryan tedder and
onerepublic and separate portfolio with
hits from lord and the weeknd for over 1
billion
dollars big ticket catalogs sold in
recent years include those from taylor
swift to paul simon neil young and bob
dylan
the deal making is driven by two factors
firstly a music industry recovery from
the dark days of illegal napster
downloads and the collapse of cd sales
secondly a decade of rock bottom
interest rates that has forced music
investors to hunt for yield
far from corporate bonds in esoteric
assets like music
fueled by streaming industry-wide music
revenue increased 7.4
to 21.6 billion dollars in 2020 the
sixth consecutive year of growth after
over a decade of decline
analysts at goldman sachs predict
revenues will nearly double by 2030
which is why pe has grown interested
based on streaming growth and the
ability to generate new revenues by
embedding songs in video games or
tick-tock videos firms expect to earn
double-digit returns
music catalogs in this sense are hardly
different than new yield plays such as
owning portfolios of taco bell
franchises
to pharmaceutical royalties for
automotive loans
as the music money pours in multiples
are skyrocketed from three to four times
the historic value of a catalog to
upwards of 20 times an assets historical
annual income in some reason deals
risks are everywhere from overpaying to
the threat of rising interest rates
there's also the risk a songwriter
simply does not gel with their private
equity overlords
in 2020 taylor swift's music catalog was
sold for about 300 million dollars amid
a bitter dispute with its owners scooter
braun and carlyle group
to strike revenge swift re-recorded the
music in the portfolio putting it back
under her control
her album red
taylor's version had 26 songs make
billboard's hot 100 list in november
[Music]
you